jeff passan from the uh mothership
joining us on short notice jeff thanks
for joining us i hate to focus on just
one thing but we're
trying to figure out what was happening
in real time with the dodgers and justin
turner
and when everybody like why did this
test come back
during the middle of game six of the
world series
boy is that a great question dan and and
the
one now there are two things that i'm
still
a little confused about the first is
that i was told that the tests from
monday
which should have been back before game
time on tuesday before game six
had not arrived the results arrived in
the second inning
and they said that justin turner's test
was
inconclusive it showed some signs uh
that he might be positive and
right around then the tests that were
taken on tuesday the day of game six had
arrived in utah
at major league baseball's lab for covet
19 testing
and they said don't rerun that original
inconclusive test let's just go straight
to the new one
and spin that sucker and it takes about
two hours to get results
and in between the second inning when
they had the inconclusive test from
monday
and the seventh inning when they had uh
finally gotten the results from
tuesday's testing
they realized that tuesdays came back
positive called up the dodgers said get
him out of the game
as soon as you can and that's why justin
turner sat down
uh and everything that happened happened
okay but he's been around his teammates
we've had no
positives for 58 days
i don't know if baseball ran the risk of
leaving him in the game since he had
already
been around his teammates he you know
here he is in the seventh inning here
i i don't know if reporters i don't know
if you or kenny rosenthal
like you guys found out and baseball had
to do this
i mean i hate to be cynical or skeptical
with this but it's kind of crazy it's
just
one unfolded right it's it's
yeah it's it's totally crazy and it's
totally ridiculous i will say this
though
uh and correct me if i'm wrong here
because i might be off but i think if
justin turner had tested positive and
had remained
in isolation it would have been
a part of this story but it would not
have been the focus like it is right now
and the fact that he was out there on
the field the fact that he went out
there with a mask but took it down
taking pictures with his wife and took
it off when he was sitting next to
the world series trophy on his left and
dave roberts his manager
uh a cancer survivor on the right who
was also
masculist uh you know andrew friedman
talked about
the optics and how the optics were were
bad if that's the case and the optics
were bad but
i mean it goes beyond optics too right
like it's just
it's a health thing and and it's a
bummer
that baseball had done as well as it had
for as long as it had and then when
something like this happened
it was pulled off in such a
slipshod um just ugly way
and and i don't think you know what to
me i don't think it takes away
from what dodgers did and from the
meaning of this
i think when we look back five or ten
years from now we're going to look back
and say that the dodgers won the world
series for the first time in 32 years
but in the moment it just it feels wrong
and it looked wrong
and uh you know you can you can have a
lot of excuses you can say
he's been around uh his teammates and
people in the organization
uh in close quarters he rode the bus
with them
over to the park that day a 20-minute
bus ride
so clearly he was uh you know close
enough to people
uh for more than 15 minutes that they're
pretty much all going to be contacts
with him at this point and that
all the people who he ran into on the
field were people who he had run into
already otherwise but even still
you know baseball had had done such a
good job
up until this point and it's just it's
unfortunate that
it went the way that it did yeah imagine
if there was a game seven
like oh my goodness like hey you know
it's interesting you say that
because let's say blake snow hadn't been
pulled out of the game let's say he
continued
to shove the way that he was and justin
turner's covet test came back positive
number one justin turner's not going to
be playing in a game seven number two
it's going to be at least two days until
another game seven and if there are more
positive tests that come
in it's gonna delay it again and again
and again and we're just gonna be
sitting here
for for lord knows how long while this
whole thing happens and
uh you know i i hope i hope like hell
that there are no other positive tests
that come back
but if there were imagine that these
players have to sit out
you know upward of two weeks and the
dodgers are going out there for a game
seven
playing uh with a roster that's
you know three quarters its normal size
that they're missing multiple
players who they would have there in a
normal situation
i mean major league baseball is thanking
its lucky stars right now that this was
the outcome
we're talking to jeff passin from espn
the great baseball reporter when
i watched blake snell through the first
four innings and it seemed to be
cruising
and i know what the analytics were when
he gets to the fifth inning
but i'm just not sure this got the dodge
or this got the
raise here i understand that they are
based in analytics
i just didn't know if anybody talked to
anybody like the catcher did anybody say
blake wants to stay in there i just
didn't know this this is the world
series
this is game six guys have a propensity
to step
up even higher taller in a bigger moment
i didn't know if
blake snell all of a sudden was not
getting
bite on his curveball didn't have
velocity didn't have location
all i know is what mookie betts said
after the game jeff he's like basically
thank god he got out of there because i
had a chance to get a hit
it's it's really interesting and i want
to i want to make a comparison that
i i haven't heard a whole lot dan
24 hours earlier clayton kershaw was out
on the mound having gotten two outs on
two pitches in the sixth inning and dave
roberts walked out there
and got absolutely booed to death by all
the dodger fans who were at the stadium
there
and we're not sitting here today talking
about the dodgers
as as world champions who were based on
analytics what the rays did was really
no different
than what the dodgers did now you can
make the argument that blake snell has
better stuff than clayton kershaw and
it's true and you can make the argument
that blake smell
looked just as sharp as he did but but
that's also
you know running into the the fallacy of
what you've done
is what you're going to do that's not
always the case we just
this will be like an all-time
you know what could have been and and we
we
think because he was so great beforehand
that he was going to continue that and
and me
if i'm the manager if i'm kevin cash
yeah i'm probably keeping him in there
but
i i'm i'm saying that from a position of
privilege
where a i don't have to make those
decisions yeah but anderson hadn't
pitched well
jeff that was my point is i'm bringing
in a guy who has struggled
if you're gonna tell me that blake snell
third time around is gonna struggle let
me
i'm gonna keep you in until you give up
a hit and then
you know that i know that and then we we
will part ways on the mound but until
then
i mean admittedly dan he had just given
up a hit okay
right yes like he like austin barnes had
hit the last pitchy through which was
the 94.3
mile per hour fastball which was his
lowest of the night
up the middle you know blake snell had
been sitting at 96
all night now i i'm i'd like to think
i'm smart enough
not to base my analysis of a player on a
single pitch that he threw blake snell
could have come out
and thrown the next one at 97 for all i
know um
you know the velocity on his off speed
pitches in that inning thus far
had been consistent with the other ones
that he had thrown and mookie had not
hit left-handers he had not hit snell
i mean yep i i i'm not basing this off
the results because in the moment i said
yeah you know what i would definitely
leave him in there um
i mean i will say this dan it's
incredible that uh mookie betts corey
seeger and justin turner who have been
uh awesome all three of them this post
season went over six with six punch-outs
against blake snell the first two times
through the order you don't know
uh great job and thank you again for all
the times that you got up and joined us
on the program the entire season uh
always entertaining
we're thinking though your voice reminds
us of a younger
keith morrison from nbc dateline
i i'll take that that guy rules
can you can you say oh
that pesky dna
i would love to okay okay hold on
sorry i haven't slept yet so i don't
know how it's going to come out
okay oh that pesky dna
uh enjoy the offseason jeff thanks for
joining us safe travels home
gentlemen the pleasure is always mine
thanks for having me that's jeff passing
from the mothership